Sathya Narayanan: if you… actually, I can show it to you on Canvas as well. Like I said, we have some…
Sathya Narayanan: homebook for you, right? These are… I know it looks like a long list, but hopefully you'll find all of them… all of them useful as you… as you're going through it.
Sathya Narayanan: One of the ideas that we have kind of, you know, learned from reading and thinking about this is some amount of handwriting your reflections, thinking through things by kind of handwriting things, is very helpful. So we'd like you to do at least, like, one
Sathya Narayanan: Attempt at it, so we have given you some, instructions here on,
Sathya Narayanan: What question, one of these prompts, handwrite with paper, pen, take a picture, but we also would like you to type it up, and we have given some strong and medium and weak examples here.
Sathya Narayanan: both an image and a text entry will be helpful. Sometimes it's difficult to read students' handwriting, that's why we're asking for both text entry and the file upload. So there is an assignment like that. The Know Yourself Dojo you just started, it will be saved locally.
Sathya Narayanan: So you will have whatever you did until now. So, continue on that, and update it, and complete that activity. You should spend, like, a decent… depending on your situation, but a good amount of time figuring that out.
Sathya Narayanan: And then we have a similar activity, which is more about knowing the market, so,
Sathya Narayanan: And we have the… we have the link here, and again, I will add more API credits, so you shouldn't… you shouldn't have the problem. This one has you…
Sathya Narayanan: think through where the market is in the space that you are interested in. Remember, we talked about knowing your niche requires you to know yourself, and know the market, and find the overlap between that, right? So this is the second activity, so this should be another 30-45 minutes or so.
Sathya Narayanan: And then here, you're just getting started, you don't have to finish this, it is just getting started on your niche doc. There is a,
Sathya Narayanan: Template that we have given, you can make a copy of it, and then start working on as many of the questions as you can answer from this.
Sathya Narayanan: And use that as a starting point, and you will update it each week. So make a copy of it, and submit the copy, and every time you submit a Google Doc, whether it's a spreadsheet or a document, make sure that it is set up with anyone with link and comment, so that we can comment and help you, right? Like, whether it's a resume, or…
Sathya Narayanan: the Google Docs, or the spreadsheet, always. So this is another assignment.
Sathya Narayanan: Another last one is a self-check. It's not published yet, it will publish it in the next 24 hours. It's basically, you are checking yourself, was this… was all of this helpful for me? Were all of this helpful for me? What should be different?
Sathya Narayanan: like, how should I think about it, and how should we think about helping you, right? So it's kind of like a self-check reflection.
Sathya Narayanan: So those are the assignments. Again, it looks like there's, what, like, 5 of them? But it's probably, you know, 30 to 45 minutes, 30 to 40… sorry, yeah, 30 minutes, 30 to 45 minutes, 30 to 45 minutes. This is, like, 15 minutes, 20 minutes, and this is another 15-20 minutes.
Sathya Narayanan: So this is about, like, I don't know.
Sathya Narayanan: 3 hours of work or something like that over the week. You should be spending a lot more than that on your job search, if you're looking for a job, so hopefully it doesn't feel, like, overwhelming.
Sathya Narayanan: So those are the things we would like you to do before you come to the session next week.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? Any of these things, if you have questions, please post them on Slack.
Sathya Narayanan: we will respond. Nancy mentioned about, like, you know, all of us are on Slack, so one of us can quickly get back to you. And, you know, others may have the same question, and you may see others' questions, so you can see the answers too, so please stay engaged on Slack.
Sathya Narayanan: So that's the… kind of the rest… rest of the week planned for you, and then we'll… we'll see you again next… next, Monday.
Sathya Narayanan: Any questions on… Kind of the homework, or what we did, or any technical difficulties that we can resolve.
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah, so can you get, like, maybe a thumbs up if things are okay, or, like.
Jeff D'Andria: I really encourage y'all to, you know.
Jeff D'Andria: put all you can into this. A lot of your peers that are just doing this alone, that don't have a community to do it with, and…
Jeff D'Andria: This is… you're gonna get a lot of… this is the time to lean into it, do the… you're gonna get a lot of course correction.
Jeff D'Andria: you know, here in these next few weeks, and then you're gonna shoot off and be doing this on your own and stuff, so… really lean into this. This is gonna be really good.
Sathya Narayanan: Okay, if there are no questions, I think, like, that's the… so we even, like, 3 minutes ahead of time.
Sathya Narayanan: We will hang around until, like, everybody's left, so all the students have left at least, so if you would like to kind of stay back and ask questions, that's okay too, if you feel uncomfortable with everybody.
Sathya Narayanan: Otherwise have a great, rest of the evening. I know some of you are on the East Coast time, so…
Sathya Narayanan: Good night, I guess, and I'll see you in… we'll see you in a,
Sathya Narayanan: Like, next week, yeah.
Sathya Narayanan: Thanks, everyone.
Nancy Rios: Thanks, everyone.